GLAD YOU CAN JOIN US.
ALEXANDER RO MARNER.
BUMPED BY GALLAGHER.
GOT AWAY AND LEFT IT FOR MARNER.
HERE'S MUZZIN WITH THE  BY DVOR.
HE GETS IT IN OVER THE LINE.
CENTRE. FOR
MORGAN RIELLY HAS IT.
BACK DOWN TO THE WING AND
AND THAT ONE HIGH OVER THE NET.
HOLL WITH A SHOT THAT GOT
BLOCKED.
GALLAGHER WILL LIFT IT OUT AND
IT'S ANDERSON WITH TO PUT IT, PA
SAFE LOCATION BECAUSE THEY'REAC.
PRESSURED BY HOFFMAN.
HE LEAVES IT ON THE BOARDS.
TIGHT.
AUSTON MATTHEWS.
GOT IT ON HAND.
ALLEN WITH A STOP, ARADE "A"
QUALITY SCORING CHANCES AND A
LITTLE HAIL MARY OVER THE TOP
PETRY BACK TO THE NET.
HANDS IOM
TO BREAK THE PUCK OUT.
>> John: AUSTON MATTHEWS TO
MUZZIN WITH A
THIS ONE FOLLOWS HIM.
NUMBER 58STUDIO TALKING
ABOUT IN PARTICULAR HOW HE WORKS
HIMSELFG FOR TAVARES.
BACK TO RIITHING ABOUT THE
LEAFS' POWER PLAY IS THEY DONNE
NET.
HE'LL SHOOT.
REBOUND IN FRONT.OFF THE
RIGHT POST.
THAT LEADS TO THIS TWO ON ONE
CHANCE WHERE SUZUKI FRONT.
BROKEN UP BY EVANS.
HE CATCHES CAUFIELD OUT OF TTELD
COMING OUT OF THE BOX AA THE MIT
FOR.
HE WATCZIN.
ON MUZZIN.CK.
MARNER TAKES A BIT OF A LOOK UP
NYLANDER IN ALONE!KE THE PLAY.
STOPPED BY MONTEM 3-0
AS NYLANDER GOES OFF TO THE
RACES ON A CLEAR-CUT BREAKAWAY.
LOTS OF TIME TO THINK A SCORES!
NOT ONLY DOES HE KNOCK IT DOWN,
JUST A REAL GOOD SHIFT FOR THE
TAVARES LI BY DAUPHIN.
EDMUNDSON WITH A SHOT.
GOESTHE NET.
WATCHED BY MIKHEYEV.
BUMPED BY HALL.
SHOT BY COLE CAUFIELD.
HE STEP
MATTHEWS ITAK
TO GALLAGHGHT BY HOF
WHAT WE CLOCKED IT AT WHEN IT
CLIPPED HIM.
THAT WILLBOARDS.
JOY IN OFF GALLAGHER.
CHANCE FOR THE EQUALIZER FOR THH
MORGAN RIELLY TO WILLIAM
NYLANDER.TO AUSTON MATTHEWS
HERE'S MATTHEWS.
ONE-TIMER.
HE GOT HISP PLAY.
AE NEUTRAL ZONE, AUSTON